SPEAKER: We live in a world
of exponential technological
advancements.
What this literally means is
that we have new construction
kits for our reality,
new tools with which
to probe at the
adjacent possible.
So consider the implications.
As Marshall McLuhan used to
say, first we build the tools,
and then the tools build us.
We are designed by
what we have designed.
There are these feedback loops
of mind, tool, and world that
radically redefine our
boundaries, that radically
transform what it
means to be human.
To be human today is to
criss-cross the skies.
To be human today is to create
technosocial wormholes ,
mind-to-mind communication that
overcomes the limits of time,
the limit of space,
and distance.
So what do we do?
Well, we need to radically
reach out to one another
in ways we haven't before.
There's a great line that
says, empathy rarely extends
beyond our lin-of-sight.
In other words, if it's out
of sight, it is out of mind.
But if anything, these wireless
communication technologies
are radically extending
our line-of-sight.
They provide new ontological
maps of the real.
They're giving us the
astronaut overview effect.
We are seeing the
big picture; we
are seeing that we are the
captains of spaceship earth.
And what shall we do?
We need to extend our
hands to one another.
We never had such
tools to overcome
all of the limitations
of our humanity.
We have the power,
we have the will,
we have the capacity,
the creative capacity,
to overcome our limits.
And so today, billions of
us linking to one another,
creating a global
node, a global brain.
What is the new
definition of billionaire?
The new definition
of billionaire
is he who will positively affect
the lives of a billion people.
He or she who will
reach out and say I
will positively affect the
lives of a billion people.
This should be our goal.
This is our responsibility.
Here's our chance.